we've all been digesting the reports and
the evidence that was in it what's been
your reaction to the level of detail in
that report well I haven't actually read
the report obviously I've seen the
newspapers and things and seen the news
and it's pretty shocking stuff but
certainly not surprised by why you're
not surprised I mean this has been
coming for a long time the evidence has
been building slowly you know Tyler
Hamilton's book etc etc this ongoing
investigation now it's just pretty much
nearly three years now this has been
going on and it was always going to come
to a head and that head is today where
you know it's been released and it's
pretty damning stuff what effect do you
think it will have on Lance Armstrong's
reputation both inside cycling and the
wider world well I think there's going
to be a mixture really there'll be the
the via a lot of people still think he's
innocent and what he's done outside of
cycling will stand for more than what he
did in cycling nothing there's obviously
a half the you know see see is what he
achieved now there's nothing anymore
so there'll be a mixture it is obviously
a massive you know reaction to this in
in different ways in them
it's how the spook sport sort of moves
forward now which is which is more
important for us still involved in it do
you see it as irrefutable evidence
yeah I think so I don't think you know
you have to be it is I say it's pretty
damning stuff as Dave described it yes
is pretty jaw-dropping and it's in a lot
of detail as well so and the amount of
people that testified against it it's
you know it's certainly as I saw some of
the quotes on the ticker tapes along on
Sky News there that it's certainly not a
one-sided hatchet job it certainly seems
to be pretty damning what does effect
what effect does it have on you what
does it effect does it have a new report
well the effect it has on me as the
current winner the Tour de France's so
I've got to answer the question to pick
up the pieces expect to be the voice of
everyone else behind me which I'm not
happy about doing really but I
understand why I have to do it
my focus is always on trying to be
better and compete next to you again and
you know almost kind of showing from the
rooftops well look what I did this year
really you know that is the future of
cycling this kind
and that is the future of our sport and
that's where it moves forward really and
obviously a lot of this stuff happened
nearly 15 years ago so it's the sport
has changed considerably and we're a big
part of maker have changing that a sport
it wasn't the past but the authorities
now have to pick up the pieces and deal
with it so what should you see I deal
with this you said well I don't know I
don't know what they do now what do they
do I mean
stripping movies titles and give it to
the second place has already tested
positive is well I'm being banned from
the sort give it to the third place is
already subsequently being gone I mean I
think it was one report in 2003 that
have to go down to fifth place to award
the victory too so there's almost it's
the most irrelevant now really there's a
void in those seven years that Lance won
the Tour so it's a shame in cycling that
the race that I have won this year this
historical race is probably now going to
be without a winner of those seven years
which is quite sad in a way but yes it's
kind of what where does that go from
there really I mean what what happens to
that those history books is that why
some cyclists still admire him because
he was the best of the bunch it was the
best of the Chiefs there were so many
people here maybe it was yeah but I
think his well from what you know he
certainly had the funding to to be the
best at that I mean is like another
sport in itself really so yeah it's not
not something really sort of should get
into maybe there's the best of that
because it's kind of it's gone away from
sport in a way it's not what sport is
about and it's certainly not why I do it
so it's quite sad talking about it in
those terms really